so if you could make a list of like the
top five things that that guys should
avoid when it comes to inviting
environmental estrogens from things they
put on their skin or things they put in
their body what would the top five
things be for you
unfiltered drinking water or drinking
water from plastic bottles can you
explain why drinking water is such an
issue
yeah so Plastics leech estrogen
chemicals they're called phthalates
they're called BPA bisphenols and and by
the way BPA
oftentimes not used anymore so it'll say
BPA free on the label but then the
companies just use BPS
so they just manipulate the molecule a
little bit it still acts like estrogen
in fact it's probably worse for you than
BPA but they Market it as BPA free so
people assume it's okay now and by the
way just let me just step back for a
second we'll keep going on the top five
but okay I don't think we mentioned this
last time
um
because we didn't talk as much about the
estrogens but
um in the 1930s there was a man named a
scientist named uh Charles uh Charles
Dodds I believe Dodds dogs
and he developed BPA as a birth control
that's why he developed it really oh
yeah
um he made it from a compound called
diethylbestral d-e-s is the you can look
it up on Wikipedia Des
because there's such a thing as desk
babies Des babies
and I know a bunch of them a lot of them
follow me because I've raised a lot of
awareness on this just by writing my
book and talking about it because this
was a a drug a prescription drug that
doctors were giving pregnant women for
like 50 years professionally writing
prescriptions and saying here's your
morning sickness drug Des again
diethylsylvesterol but
um and then the you know they were
taking it for morning sickness but it
was acting like estrogen in their bodies
and disrupting hormones in the fetus
and from that compound again in the
1930s the scientist made BPA
but they realized they could make a lot
more money making it into plastic
and so that's what they did
and they told everybody it doesn't Leach
they assured everybody look there's no
leaching you can make a plastic bottle
put water in there there's no leaching
into the you know of these BPA chemicals
because again it's birth control right
so people knew that they didn't want any
any of that chemical but they did a big
marketing campaign really really pushed
it doesn't Leach it doesn't Leach
doesn't Leach the government got behind
it like they usually do and there's a
lot of money involved and
you know obviously it leeches I mean now
it's very clear it's super super obvious
thousands of scientific studies showing
number one how bad BPA is for you and
number two much it leeches so of course
BPA BPA free is a common thing now
they're using VPS just so people know
so any so any plastic container for
water or food is going to Leach and uh
estrogen well if it's liquid compound in
your body yeah if you have liquids if
you have liquids in the plastic what
about the um what about the issue with
birth control ending up in the drinking
water is that still a problem oh yeah
yeah can you explain that
yeah so they don't filter out micro
molecules like birth can
so the Municipal Water Supplies or the
municipal water filtration systems the
treatment plants they're good at killing
viruses they're good at killing bacteria
but they don't filter out birth control
and a lot of things honestly like a lot
of prescription drugs end up in there
too okay and people are drinking this
stuff and it's that comes from urine
right like women take the birth control
pill that ends up with urine through the
water system it's a hormone they can't
get it out
yeah exactly good point and uh and and
it's specifically designed for your body
not to break it down right like they
make that chemical
intent like they make birth control
molecules with the intention that your
body doesn't break it down so it stays
in your body longer and it works at a
lower dose and all this kind of thing
okay and so and same with a lot of these
pesticides and herbicides that end up in
the drinking water so even if you live
in like like Metals nowhere yeah
atrazine is one of the one I was going
to mention I mean if you live in farm
country
where there's there's nobody peeing in
your drinking water you still end up
with a lot of these chemicals that act
like estrogen leaching into your water
so if you have a well dug then you could
technically have atrazine in your well
yeah oh yeah so what so to solve this
problem with number one with water
um a a reverse osmosis water filter is
that the best way to go or is there
something better than that
that's what I use yeah okay so like a
five stage like it's got those five
different canisters like that'll get out
the estrogens oh yeah yeah literally
anything with activated charcoal if
you've got a filter that has does that
work oh yeah British have activated
charcoal okay the problem is a lot of
people filter it and they put it back
into plastic
right because potatoes are plastic I've
not seen a glass filter system yet yeah
me neither so they make they make uh
filters that you can screw onto your
sink
um and just go direct into your cup it
like flips up and flips down those right
yeah the other thing some people do is
they filter it into the plastic and then
they immediately pour it into glass
that's fine too the longer something
sits in plastic the more leaching you're
going to have so it's only if it's only
in there for a day or two it's a
short-term thing it's not a big deal
and what about ultraviolet light does
that does that amplify it like if you
leave a plastic water bottle in your car
for like an hour you go to the gym and
you come back and it's scalding hot like
you've got now
environmental estrogens in your plastic
water yeah heat increases leaching oils
increase leaching so if you have olive
oil in a plastic jar you end up a lot
more leaching than if you had water in
that plastic jar so do not buy olive
oils in a plastic jar yeah
in fact a lot of scientific research on
oils uh it tells you that this oil is
bad and that oil is bad and honestly a
lot of it's just the problems from the
estrogens that are leaching into the
oils now seed oils I'm not a fan of I
mean just just across the board if it
comes from a seed and it's an oil it's
probably bad for you but like fruit oils
like olives and avocados and coconut
oils those are generally pretty good for
you but you definitely don't want to buy
those in Plastics because again then
you're going to have a lot of extra
leaching and that's where you get these
scientists that tell you those oils are
bad most scientists agree those oils are
fine but the ones that argue that those
oils are bad are the ones looking at
those studies that are from plastic jars
honestly
okay so plastic jars water what would be
the next one that would be right up
there close to the top of the list
personal care across the board I mean
the the Soaps people are rubbing on
their skin you know the fragrances in
those soaps you have to be careful a lot
of these companies they use the term
fragrance on the label so they don't
actually tell you what's in the product
and that's legally allowed so they can
put parabens and phthalates and all
kinds of Shenanigans in the product
and they don't have to tell you and
those go through your skin right it's
just like rubbing hormone cream on your
skin your skin absorbs them they're oily
substances so they prefer your skin
rather than water so when you're washing
you think you're washing it off but it
actually likes to stick in your skin
just like fragrance yeah so you
mentioned
um that you tried Grande soap the
Tactical Soap Company soap like what did
you find as far as that product goes as
far oh yeah I went to bond if I didn't
think it was good
um you know I don't have a problem with
fragrances and of course pheromones with
in that case I don't have an issue with
all that the problem is companies that
are dishonest and they're sneaking in
all kinds of weird usually if you open
up something and it just smells like
overwhelming yeah yeah it's probably
some kind of fake petroleum knockoff
fragrance yeah um and yeah most of those
act like estrogen in your body you know
I get a I get heat from guys more
specifically because I have a soap I
mean they also have a beard oil too but
I have a toiletry company that sells
soap because it's pheromone infused a
lot of guys absolutely like lose their
mind like oh he's you know he's a soap
butt or he's a snake oil salesman or
something like that it's like no dude
like go go to Costco and buy your you
know 72 pack of green smelly soap and
you'll get it for a lot less but there's
a reason why it's cheaper right like
like there's phthalates there's all
kinds of things in it that when you put
it on your skin your skin absorbs it it
it does act like estrogen in your body
right I mean maybe that's part of the
reasons why they're acting like little
[__]
oh for sure I'll say it I'll say it I
will too because you know scientists see
that in animals and they have technical
terms that they can use like sexual
apathy and all this to kind of couch it
but that's basically what it is really
um oh sure male feminization it was
pretty funny uh you know they won't say
that anymore in scientific studies but
if you go to PubMed and you literally
look up studies where they just use you
put it in quotations male feminization
you'll find all kinds of studies
um but yeah I mean the reason they use
these products like you said and it's
worth reiterating yeah they're super
cheap it's petroleum you can literally
buy kilograms of this stuff for pennies
almost and yeah and so they can
rationalize it and they tell you like
I've interviewed scientists that work
for these uh fragrance companies and
they say oh we add parabens and
phthalates because it carries the
perfume further through the air it's
like it's [__] you're just putting
them in there because it's cheaper well
it smells good too I think that that
people are easily attractive to sweet
things or anything that smells good and
you know you open up that big box of 72
soaps it's like boom it's like wow that
smells good and you think that you're
you know gonna smell nice and fresh they
have all kinds of names for it like
Scottish mountain springs or something
like that you know they'll make up stuff
to get you like you know let's go and
get some of that but uh yeah like I
never thought about this before I read
your book right like when I got in your
book I'm like holy [__] now I gotta
throw this out then I gotta throw that
out
um Okay so we've talked about water
we've talked about toiletries what is it
specifically in toiletries that people
should look for is it is it just
phthalates
no they should watch for parabens too
parabens phthalates and parabens are
both broad categories it's not like BPA
is one molecule right
but parabens and phthalates like there's
methylparabin there's propyl paraben
there's butyl paraben there's a whole
there's hundreds of different parabens
so somebody says oh we've studied the
parabens and they're safe it's like
which one did you study right and the
problem is your your body breaks them
down so even the breakdown products
usually act like estrogen
um which you know most people aren't
looking at the breakdown products in
some of these uh precursor studies these
initial studies that are really just
just looking at one molecule and
arguing to the government that these
things are safe so you know sunscreen is
an interesting example that's very
similar so I recommend people are very
cautious with the sunscreen there's a
chemical in there called oxybenzone or
benzophenone it's a synonym benzophenol
and oxybenzyme and they literally have
this chemical legal for like 50 years
and just a couple years ago after I
published my book by the way they they
did a study
where they did one application of
sunscreen just one
seven days later people's blood levels
of oxybenzone were still above the
government's safety limits
um this is like cancer-causing levels of
oxybenzel really seven days after one
application of sunscreen and all kinds
of news media Outlets picked this up and
things and that they never did the study
and they do that with a lot of these
chemicals it's like well where's the
studies well if it acts like estrogen
let's just assume it's bad right I mean
that should be the Assumption for people
especially for men that don't want to
bloat up their body with a bunch of
estrogen yeah like every sunscreen
Contin so again after I read your book I
went to go look at my sunscreens was you
know one of the things I did after the
toiletries and every sunscreen had
oxybenzone in it I've noticed now a lot
of sunscreens are sold and they say
oxybenzone free but they don't have zinc
as the main ingredient so the ones that
are oxybenzone free do they just replace
it with another benzone something
another that's still dangerous they sure
did yeah they've used avobenzone and
things like this they just play the
shell game right it's just like the BPA
they're playing shell games
um you're right you want to look for the
ones that are like 20 zinc and all the
other ingredients you can pronounce like
coconut oil or something like that
those are good do you really need
sunscreen like I've heard some people
say that it's unnecessary like if you
stay out of the Sun during the like
start of the spring season between you
know like 11 and 2 you kind of build up
like a natural resistance to it and then
you can kind of like I find that I don't
really need sunscreen by the end of the
summer time like I'm on a boat a lot in
the summer and on the water and stuff I
find that it's just fine is it yeah is
it necessary to have sunscreen if you've
got like a like you're more kind of like
a redhead like paler sort of complexion
but somebody with sort of like darker
hair darker skin would they be okay
without sunscreen I didn't use sunscreen
at all last year okay and uh I'd go
fishing all day long on the ocean I was
mahi-mahi fishing and all kinds of stuff
like that long sleeve shirt hats still
but yeah yeah if it's peak hours of the
day it's funny man when I go fishing I
literally take off my shirt I'm out
there with shorts you know fishing and I
set a timer for 20 minutes or I watch my
phone or whatever
and 20 30 minutes into it if it's you
know a hot afternoon day or whatever
um I'll after I get my son I try and get
sunshine and then I put on the sun shirt
the sun hat the sun sometimes even Sun
gloves if I'm fishing
but I'm not opposed to sunscreen either
I just it's it's just easier to put on
clothing it's just got to be zinc based
yeah exactly it's got to be good quality
stuff and um
you know and again sunshine is
beneficial a lot of these doctors
telling people to never get sunshine and
stay out of the Sun and always put
sunscreen on if it's terrible for you
right I mean Sunshine detoxes your body
and I know it sounds kind of silly to
say it like that but it does it breaks
the [__] down like if you've got tattoos
you know this because your tattoo Fades
away if you go out in the sun right like
stuff breaks down when you have sunshine
and the same thing happens with garbage
building up in your cells you know heavy
metals building up
um that stuff is broken down with
Sunshine it accelerates that process
helps your body get rid of it yeah last
time you were telling me that one of the
one of the great ways to get rid of
estrogen in your body is to sweat it out
so using a sauna right
and that also gets rid of heavy metals
and other toxins in your body it sort of
like leaves Through Your Skin So it's so
it sort of taxes your kidneys less too
if I understand yeah yeah saunas are
unbelievable or sweating in general I
mean saunas have a unique Advantage
because they increase heat shock
proteins so we have these little whiskey
barrel-shaped proteins they literally
look like whiskey barrels under a
electron microscope they're pretty cool
looking things and after a while your
proteins get kind of beat down it's kind
of like a car right like your car gets
kind of beat down
and if you have heat shock proteins they
go into these little whiskey barrels and
basically get refurbished it's like a
refurbishing Center for proteins and
sweating like if you go out to the gym
and you just work out really hard your
body doesn't really increase heat shock
proteins but if you go to the sauna
and you really amp up the heat and you
stress out your body with heat you
increase heat shock proteins
dramatically so it's kind of like
fasting you get a lot of the same types
of benefits you would get from
intermittent fasting or something where
your body just has to uh tighten up a
little bit clean up a little right clean
up some debris and some garbage and take
out the trash you know is there a is
there a difference between infrared
saunas and just dry saunas or is it
pretty much the same effect with heat
shock proteins
the heat shock proteins are pretty much
the same as long as you're getting heat
stress I like infrared because you know
it actually eats you from the inside and
uh infrared itself has its own side
benefits like it increases nitric oxide
for example um
um and that's beneficial in a lot of
different ways blood flow and uh good
for heart good for bedroom fun it's good
for a lot of things yeah
yeah so but they're both good and so
sweating in the gym I mean if you want
to just get rid of estrogens from your
sweat sweating in the gym is perfectly
sufficient for that component you just
don't get the heat shock proteins it's
all good sweating is great got it okay
so um so back to the top five so we got
water uh toiletries sunscreen what would
the next one be for you
probably soy I mean soy is everywhere oh
this is good this is going to anger a
lot of people Anthony I know I've been
in what a vegan's gonna do I've been
invited on vegan podcasts before I
actually invited it at a vegan
conference one time to speak and then
they found out I was against soy and
they removed their invitation wow
okay so what's the final word on soy
then
it's estrogen every scientist agrees it
acts like estrogen nobody disagrees with
that some people say it's good estrogen
right and some people will say it's bad
estrogen I'm in the camp that says it's
bad estrogen for a lot of reasons but
one of the reasons is we have enough
estrogen as it is in our culture we were
getting bombarded with estrogen the last
thing we need is more estrogen you know
like the problem with a lot of these soy
studies is our bodies are so washed out
with so much estrogen if you add a
little bit more from soy it doesn't you
don't see an effect and then people say
oh look it doesn't do anything well it
does but you're already filled up with
bpas and phthalates and all this crap I
mean check people's urine the levels are
insane
so it's harder to see an effect when
your body's all washed out with estrogen
but that doesn't mean it's not causing
an effect and the other aspect of it is
the vegans have like a technical
argument where they talk about the alpha
and beta receptors from estrogen and it
kind of gets in the weeds and I'm happy
to entertain that argument but I have
counterpoints to that too and and you
know I don't I I think I've even done
some technical YouTube videos if people
search Anthony J soy or something they'd
probably find those technical arguments
okay so water toiletry sunscreen soy
what would the fifth one be
um
good question
I mean we're talking about the most
common estrogen exposures right yeah I
think the ones I think that was
problematic yeah I think the grains that
are not organic when people are just
eating grains all the time
a lot of these pesticides and herbicides
that they use on the grain specifically
atrazine being the most prominent and
glyphosate being the next boss they act
like estrogen atrazine is extremely
estrogenic glyphosate is also estrogenic
a little bit I didn't even write about
that in my book by the way because I
wasn't sure about it at the time it
doesn't look you know the glyphosate
molecule it looks like glycine that's
where they get the word glyphosate it's
basically glycine with a phosphate group
it kind of looks like an amino acid
right it looks like a building block for
proteins it does not look like an
estrogen so I wasn't totally convinced
then there was just a few studies at the
time but now there's a lot more studies
and they're they're very convincing that
glyphosate acts like estrogen
and
I think it's because
uh glyphosate sticks to Metals right
it's called a chelator it's
c-h-e-l-a-t-e you know chelate chelates
metal so it binds to Metals so magnesium
in your body gets drawn out from
glyphosate calcium gets drawn out zinc
gets drawn out right glyphosate sticks
to these metals and and basically causes
your body to get rid of them through the
stool
and if you've got uh glyphosate stuck to
magnesium
and you and you've got another molecule
of glyphosate stuck to magnesium and
another one now it starts to look like
estrogen so I think it's because of the
chelation it's because it's sticking to
metals and you're getting like a malt up
you're getting a multiple chains of uh
of glyphosates stuck together
so the long story short is people should
watch out for grains right because every
freaking grain in America is sprayed
with glyphosate yeah or atrazine or both
if it's not organic I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out